the jurogan experience so the derrick
brunson fight which is coming up soon
what is your what are your thoughts on
derek brunson i mean we talked about a
little bit earlier but
you know he's obviously a veteran he's
obviously a guy's been around he's
fought
stylebender he's the shibazian fight his
last fight i thought he looked [ __ ]
fantastic
yeah and shibazi and that was an
interesting situation right
you got this kid who's 21 years old
super dangerous
real fast hands looked great but never
really been
tested against like a veteran and then
you saw
wasn't really ready for that yet yeah
brent is good you know his wrestling's
good
uh his standup's a little wild he hits
hard uh
you know it's like it is it's gonna be a
fun fight but it's like you know but
the problem is is it's like when he gets
in there with the top level guys you
know
he hasn't had a lot of success and and
we're just going to find out if kevin's
is as top level as i think he is you
know it's like it's like
he's into jenga yeah yes you know that
part where he goes
you know rude boy there's only one out
of 10 000 [ __ ] and you'd had one out
of 10 000.
i'm that one on 10 000 we're gonna find
out
you know it's closer to like one in a
million it's like
it's just different do you feel like
this is uh like a pivotal moment
can you clearly it can be it very much
can be i
but me and derek brunson we have a lot
of words back and forth yeah yeah
no no no kevin [ __ ] with derek bronson
constantly
it's like but kevin does this to
everybody he started everybody's he's
starting he's like
he's in he's in the style benders in the
inbox he's in
everybody's inbox and he's [ __ ] do
you dm's these guys yeah yeah all the
time
do they go back and forth oh yeah some
of them all the time really eric does
something very good
who goes back and forth with you mike
perry's nice enough to go back and forth
with me does he i like that guy he does
he's funny he [ __ ] with him he [ __ ]
with him and then you know brunson
brunson started it though
he told me he's going to slam me on my
head so [ __ ] him and then uh
you know it's just there's a few of them
that was what he opened with yeah i'm
gonna slam you on your head yeah chemist
doesn't go back and forth with me so
that no
that's not come on i don't know he says
he's about that life that kid ain't
about that life
um i see him at the pi and i walked in i
was like that's my best friend he was
like you want to be friends now
i was like [ __ ] no it's like never i was
like best friends without being friends
they were like kevin there was a lot of
them they were going to jump you and i
was like no i drove out here
i got dildos in the car i was ready to
[ __ ] them you know so
that boy's not about that life do you
don't you think that i mean it's it's
it's very unfortunate that he's
suffering from covet that he's got this
long-term situation where apparently
when i i've talked to doctors about this
i'm like what is going on with that
and they said when you're training
really hard and then you're breaking
down your immune system and then you get
coveted you can get it real bad
and when you get it really bad and then
you don't take care of yourself in terms
of like don't give yourself adequate
time to recover
you go back in before you're really
fully recovered and also
you're not taking care of all the
inflammation issues that you have with
your diet with with your supplements
yeah you hit a situation like him where
he had to pull out leon edwards fight
imagine being [ __ ] leon edwards one
of the best fighters in the world
can't get a fight can't get a fight he's
fighting below finally
finally blau steps up right after
winning i offered to step up the last
time
kevin was in there kevin was in the
right boxes again [ __ ] hell fighting
i have zenbox leon plenty of times he
doesn't respond
and then the thing about it is a lot of
these guys can say before that i didn't
have the followers so they didn't see
the message
now i have the followers so you're
seeing the [ __ ] message you're just
choosing not to respond
you know what i mean it's like like if
we're being real here these guys half
these guys who claim that they're
fighters
they're fighters because it pays a bill
and it looks good online
it looks good on tv is that the case or
are they being
calculated about what risks they take
you're not a fighter if you're
calculating risk
really though do you think that's true i
mean if you're a first year fighter
he's talking about life and it's like
you know he's he's not talking about
his career right now he's talking about
he's talking about
the mind for kevin all that stuff kind
of you know melts together a little bit
you know it's like he's you know it's
like he's
he's not necessarily you know saying
that yeah these guys are for sure
fighters but they're not
real fighters in kevin's mind i
understand what you're saying yeah
they won't you know and it's like i get
happy when i see these guys step up last
second for a fight like see them below
step up for that fight i'm like okay
there you go
don't [ __ ] complain about how you're
not getting upper fights when you don't
really put yourself in that situation
and get in those fights you know
when when shamai have knocked out
mirshard i was like holy [ __ ]
yeah knocked him out with one punch i'm
like okay now i want to see
if he can do that i want to say like how
does he fare against garlic
how does he fare against other like
elite 170 or 185
which which which is weird too right
that he's just bouncing back and forth
between those two weight classes he's
bouncing back and forth to the to the
fights that make the most sense
so he'll go to 70 for a fight that makes
sense he'll come back up to 85 for a
fight that makes sense you know nothing
wrong with it good management
fighters who fight like that very smart
fighters i tip my hat off to them you
know
them and their management and their
coaches that's great that's not me i'd
never be that so props to those guys
you know but it's like if you know you
go to 70 because this fight makes sense
for you
smart moves you go back to 85 because
this fight makes sense to you smart move
i was impressed by the way he knocked
out mr sharp just because he he took the
smartest route which was keeping it
standing and i thought the guy who liked
the grapple was going to take it to the
ground
you know but knocking out mirror chart
after mirzard's coming off of
losses you know what i mean and i i know
i smacked him a couple of times
i know deron wins smacked him a couple
times you know what i mean and i know
ian heinrich
ultimately landed the last smacking and
if you i think if you add up those three
people who have decent power and have
been smacking them at 85
the the head's just not the same as they
used to be he's even fought the ago
santos right yeah
you know it's like you can't fight all
these killers and take these type of
head shots and think that you're going
to be okay if chemi has a little bit of
pop
of course it's going to look good i mean
smart
props to him for taking the smart
program every time you go out there and
fight a guy
you know it's like we both fought john
phillips i went out there and stood
stood and banged with john phillips
coach told me in the second round
go okay you already look good in the
first round go out there in the second
round take this guy down choke him out
he's obviously not trying to go away
from punches
chimaev went out there took him down
punched on him punched on and punched on
him subbed on
smart smart fighter props to him but
what happens when you can't go out there
and take an easy smart route climbs when
a fighter is really [ __ ] good that's
why i wanted like you said i want to see
the leon fight
you know i want to see that you know i
was fascinated by that fight
i would have took the new magnet fight
him versus no magnet would have been i
would have been happy with that you can
slowly work your way up i think he
you know it's like after seeing neil
magne being done the way he got done
against you know michael kiesta
i think that chimaya could have got the
job done especially being a big 170 here
but it's like it's like you know it's i
don't know
and then you sit up here and you say
it's sad because he has covered and [ __ ]
like that but they said i had covet you
know and if we're supposed to be
athletes you know it's like
yeah but you obviously had a very mild
oh yeah i mean he's
he's had it for my girl had it pretty
good months now my girl had it pretty
good and i was [ __ ] her the whole
time you know and
it's like so you know it's like you know
it's like we all take it different you
know
different fighters different heart you
know don't claim to have that heart if
you ain't got it
don't you think it's just like a disease
though i mean i mean some people just
lose the disease the flu sucks you know
michael jordan still went out there and
won
well you know difference you know i
understand what you're saying
yeah it's a bummer it's a bummer that we
don't get because it was so exciting he
watched him he's fighting back to back
he's trying to fight
he's scheduling two fights at the same
time he's you know
yeah i'm just sad because i really
wanted to see the guy fight again yeah
just said
also you wanted to fight him no not me i
don't want to fight that guy he's a
monster bro he's undefeated
smashing everybody minnie khabib i don't
want no problems with that guy
you know that's not true he was [ __ ]
with him a whole goddamn time over there
yeah you were asking for it when i
interviewed yeah i love it
i love it it well they had all right
they had kevin had words with him too
you know it's like kevin had words with
him and then they he's
he said something to kevin pisk kevin
off and kevin's you know
angry but the boss the boss has said on
interview that we're in two different
weight classes
and that we'd probably never meet up so
i'm assuming that he's staying at 870
and i'm staying at 85.
and you know it's like you know maybe
one day when he
you know gets over being a little tired
he can get back in there and get some
fights in and we'll be okay
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience